- Навпроти мене архімандрит Кирило Говорун.
Отець Кирило, спасибі велике за інтерв'ю, ласкаво просимо в програму.
- Дякую за запрошення.
- Ви до 2014 року були так чи інакше пов'язані
з Російською православною церквою, обіймали різні високі посади.
Жили, до речі, в Москві, в 2008-2009 роках
керували відділом зовнішніх зв'язків
Української православної церкви Московського патріархату.
Тепер Ви активний прихильник автокефалії Української церкви.
Що змінилося?
- Мало що змінилося. Я би так сказав,
що зараз мій профіль, головним чином -
академічний, викладацький.
Я працюю в різних університетах, західних переважно,
в університеті Ман у Лос-Анджелесі.
І моя діяльність більш академічна.  Змінилася ситуація в цілому.
Тому що почалася війна,
почалася російська агресія проти України.
Гадаю, саме ця агресія змінила загальний хід
історії в питанні автокефального руху.
Цьому руху вже понад сто років,
і тепер він перейшов в активну фазу, тому що анексія Криму
і згодом війна в Україні стали каталізатором цього процесу
і зробили його можливим.
Спроби робилися і до цього. Була спроба
в 2008 році.
Я у цей час саме був у Києві,
очолював відділ зовнішніх церковних зв'язків
і за посадою повинен був займатися цими питаннями.
- Ви були прихильником автокефалії і тоді?
- Я б іншими термінами це визначив.
Я був прихильником вирішення українського церковного питання.
Українське церковне питання,
його головна проблема - це наявність розколу,
це те що величезна кількість людей ходить до церкви,
але ця церква не є легітимною,
вона не є визнаною іншими церквами.
- Дозвольте мені поставити ось таке запитання.
Була зустріч патріарха Кирила із Вселенським патріархом Варфоломієм.
І під час їхнього, якщо можна так висловитися,
обміну думками патріарх Кирило сказав:
"Давайте, поки ви не будете надавати автокефалію Українській церкві.
Давайте почнемо діалог".
Саме те, що ви намагалися у 2008-2009 роках.
І патріарх Варфоломій сказав:
"Ні, жодних діалогів, час діяти".
- Так, дійсно аргумент про діалог наводився тоді,
коли необхідно було нейтралізувати втручання
Константинополя в українське питання.
Будь-яка спроба почати по-справжньому реальний діалог,
а не його симуляцію призводила до жорсткого опору.
Моя особиста історія така ,
що коли я був у Києві і займався цими питаннями,
ми ініціювали наприкінці серпня
2009-го року  створення комісії,
яка почала б обговорювати можливість початку діалогу.
Тобто це взагалі дуже-дуже обережний був крок.
Але для реального діалогу, а не симуляції.
А через три дні після того, як ми оголосили про свої наміри,
я дізнався з інтернету,  що мене перевели в Москву.
Тобто було очевидно, що в цьому діалозі
зацікавленості насправді не було.
- Тобто автокефалія - це все-таки багато в чому політичне питання?
- Це церковно-політичне питання.
У цього питання є безумовно дуже сильна політична складова,
тому її так і використовують політики, президент України.
Питання про автокефалію постало у зв'язку з тим,
що виник дефіцит розуміння того, що відбувається в Україні.
Якщо брати Українську православну церкву, яка знаходиться в Україні,
Українська православна церква Московського патріархату, вона, на жаль,
звузила, так би мовити, свою базу в Україні,
платформу, на якій вона могла б здійснювати
комунікацію зі суспільством,
тому що вона відмовилася визнавати війну в Україні,
просто закриває очі на цю агресію,
відмовляється визнавати реальність того,
що відбувається на Сході України.
Ось я в травні побував на лінії зіткнення, на фронті,
я бачив цю реальність. Вона дуже жорстока. Це справді війна.
Майже щодня вбивають людей, там усюди міни,
і снайпери обстрілюють вулиці, де живуть люди.
І церква відмовляється, фактично, визнавати цю проблему.
З одного боку, є неадекватне сприйняття реалій.
Якщо брати російську церкву, то вона відмовляється,
як ми побачили, визнавати реальність України.
Тобто Україна просто, виявляється, не існує
як самостійна величина.
Виявилося, що церква,
яка найбільш адекватно і реально сприймає реалії в Україні,
це Вселенський патріархат. І його дії продиктовані оцінкою, на мій погляд,
адекватною, тієї реальності, яка склалася в Україні.
- Ось ви говорите про Вселенський патріархат,
і завдання патріарха Варфоломія -
зберегти єдність православних церков.
Видно, що він абсолютний прихильник того,
щоб надати незалежність українській церкві.
То розкол у православному світі неминучий?
- Я думаю, що розколу не буде. Про нього говорять, звичайно,
але його використовують більше як риторичний прийом, ніж як реальний сценарій.
Вже тепер церкви, помісні церкви заявили про те,
що вони не збираються підтримувати розрив відносин
із жодною з конфліктуючих сторін.
Мається на увазі, Москва і Константинополь.
І, безумовно, може статися розрив відносин між двома церквами.
Частково він вже стався, тому що було рішення ...
- То це не розкол?
- Це ще не є розколом, це є розривом відносин.
Розкол - це коли є одна церква православна,
і вона поділяється на дві частини.
Так сталося, наприклад, з церквами сходу
і заходу в 11 столітті, коли вони розділилися:
Римська церква і Константинопольська церква
припинили відносини одна з одною
на особистому рівні між представниками цих церков.
І зрештою ця тріщина у відносинах між двома лідерами церков
пройшла по всій церкві, і вся церква, фактично,
розділилася на східну і західну частини,
поділ досі існує. Ми це знаємо,
як поділ між православною і католицькою церквами.
Я думаю, що зараз цього сценарію не буде.
Хоча б тому, що ось ця тріщина, яка виникла
у відносинах між Москвою і Константинополем, не піде далі.
- Ви сказали, що президент Порошенко
використовує автокефалію у своїх політичних цілях,
це буде, безумовно, політична перемога нинішнього президента України.
Але є низка наслідків.
Одні експерти кажуть, що це рішення може підштовхнути
націоналістичні настрої в країні.
Наскільки обґрунтовані такі твердження?
- Ви знаєте, про націоналістичні настрої я часто чую.
Але я б не став їх перебільшувати. Я розумію, що ця тема,
теза про український націоналізм використовується часто
для того, щоб скомпрометувати Україну як державу.
І ті процеси, які були запущені в українському суспільстві
Помаранчевою революцією, і Революцією гідності.
Хочу підкреслити, що ні перша, ні друга революції не були націоналістичними революціями.
Це були революції, влаштовані громадянським суспільством.
Більшість людей там виходили не з націоналістичним порядком денним.
Тобто там були націоналісти, звичайно,
але вони не задавали програму,
не формували програму цих виступів, цих маніфестацій.
Безумовно, нині є певне зростання націоналістичних настроїв.
Це обумовлено тим, що йде війна.
Коли йде війна, націоналізм завжди зростає.
Подивіться на Другу світову війну, що відбувалося в Америці.
В Америці був різкий спалах націоналізму.
Те саме в європейських країнах, там, де виникали конфлікти.
В Україні націоналістична реакція, скажімо так,
на війну на Сході ще на диво слабка, я б так сказав.
Подивіться, навіть без війни в європейських країнах
у парламенти масово обирають націоналістичні партії.
В Україні немає жодної націоналістичної партії в парламенті, жодної.
Вони не пройшли бар'єр. І тепер я не думаю,
що процес автокефалії є виразом націоналістичних настроїв.
Це форма захисту України від зовнішньої агресії,
де церква, на жаль, взяла на себе роль учасника цієї агресії.
. І ось цю роль, власне кажучи, намагаються
мінімізувати таким кроком.